S
NICK ROBERTSON SUPPORTS SOME OF
THEM ARE HEADED TO HER AREAS
THAT ARE CONTROLLED BY RUSSIA.
>> WAITING AND WAITING,
FAMILIES, PETS, POSSESSIONS
LOADING THEM DOWN, ALL CROSSING
TO THE RUSSIAN OCCUPIED
TERRITORY SOUTH OF
ZAPORIZHZHIA.
>> THIS IS WHAT'S SLOWING
EVERYTHING, THE DEEP MUD CARS
GETTING POP DOWN, SLIDING ALL
OVER, THIS ONE JUST MANAGING TO
GET THROUGH AND THE REASON
THEY'RE COMING THIS WAY?
QUITE SIMPLE, THE BRIDGES, UP
BLOWN UP.
>> UKRAINIAN EMERGENCY SERVICES
DOING THEIR BEST TO GET PEOPLE
THROUGH THE RAIN SODDEN FEELS,.
WE'VE HAD TO DRAG A FEW TRUCKS
OUT TODAY THE COMMANDER SAYS.
BUT IT IS DRYING OUT AND
GETTING EASIER.
KNOWN AS THE GREEN CORRIDOR IT
IS WHERE PEOPLE CROSSED TO AND
FROM RUSSIA OCCUPIED
TERRITORIES.
BUT SOME THINGS ABOUT THIS DAY,
THE TRAFFIC ALMOST ENTIRELY
ONE-WAY.
OF AN ESTIMATED 6000 PEOPLE
STUCK ON THE RUSSIAN SIDE, ONLY
76 CROSSED.
MANY, MANY HUNDREDS WENT THE
OTHER WAY.
WHERE YOU GOING?
>> TO KHERSON.
>> WHY?
>> BECAUSE MY PARENTS LIVE.
THERE >> IS A DANGEROUS BECAUSE
THE RUSSIANS ARE CONTROLLING.
>> I KNOW, BUT I MUST GO TO MY
CITY.
>> EVERYONE LEAVING
UKRAINIAN-CONTROLLED TERRITORY
IS TELLING US A SIMILAR THING.
THEY EXPECT TO COME BACK EVEN
IF IT APPEARS THEY'RE NOT.
I'M TAKING MY MOTHER TO THE
OTHER SIDE HE SAYS AND PICKING
UP MY GRANDMOTHER, WHEN WE
ASKED WISE TAKING HIS YOUNGER
DAUGHTER?
>> HE SHRUGS.
IF THEY WERE GOING TO LIVE ON
THE RUSSIAN SIDE NO ONE WILLING
TO ADMIT IT.
THE ROUTE WORKING SO WELL
SEVERAL TRUCKS WORKING THE WELL
TO TURN A PROFIT.
THIS MAN HAS OFFEND LOADED WITH
TOILET PAPER AND TAXI --
AND PEPSI.
THE EMERGENCY SERVICES HERE SAY
THAT ON A NORMAL DAY THEY GET
TRAFFIC COMING FROM THE
OCCUPIED RUSSIAN CONTROL SIDE.
TODAY IT IS DIFFERENT, THEY
UNDERSTAND THAT THERE WILL BE
NOBODY, NOBODY ELSE COMING FROM
THE RUSSIAN SIDE TODAY.
NO ONE ANY WISER BY THE